isn't it just so much easier to just you
know
[Laughter]
30 chance that's a good idea
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys and
today we have men
that's not bad thank you that and doves
be perfect
how you been man good good you're buying
like a thousand houses and Lambos now no
no more thousand house no more Lambos uh
now I'm whatever I make I'm investing in
to make more money that's all right now
in the season
yeah I know I know that's a boring part
Perpetual investing you got a set
percentage do you go like half or like
80. my new model is I look for talented
young people okay that can do something
with social I'm pretty talented and then
I find them and I find out what are they
good at because right now
um you know as more businesses are
switching to social media
they all want to learn social media so
you just find people who are good at it
that don't have money and you partner
with them like I have a someone who's
good at writing scripts all right let me
partner with you do a script course
you're good at running ads let me
partner with you doing running ads
survive what about a Lambo or waste
money on doves then I can't partner with
these people so if you're supposed to
inspire them without dozen Lambos yeah I
think the new generation has changed I
think it's the The Changing of the Guard
where it's okay to live poor it's okay
not to have I started yeah close you did
I started for real I don't know no kids
like that most of these kids right now
they want to like they want to invest
they want to they're down driving
Priuses you know they are I'll see kids
I'm like how the [ __ ] you afford 200
shoes because I had 220. I'm like damn
you're crazy man younger like these
Hustler guys that they're all about
making money right now so if they don't
have any it's like I feel like I'm the
sugar daddy and they're the sugar baby
and I'm like like I get their youth
right now until they figured it out they
get the away from school then they'll
probably leave me but then at that point
I've already got what I wanted out of
and what are you doing with them you're
partnering to make to do business to do
courses like if I want to do a course
I'm going to partner with this person
this person like what do businesses need
right now everyone wants to run their
business through social so okay this
person's good at writing scripts let me
create a course script with them let
them do all the writing I'll be the face
so I get to be the Pinocchio there I
they are the Geppetto but I'm the one
pushing the brand out there so instead
of buying expensive things like cool how
much do I need to spend on this person
what am I going to get out of it so this
is not even real estate anymore you're
just building social media correct
because real estate right now I would
save and just wait for the the market to
turn on real estate I'm investing in
other people because they have so much
potential it's like let's like if you
had to run a race I'd invest in you
right now before you get tired and then
whenever you get somewhere then then you
can either Branch off or keep going with
me if I keep investing with you because
some people they want someone to invest
in them and they don't want to use any
of their own money and there's certain
people or they don't even have money
correct but then when they have money
you start seeing their personality are
they alpha or beta if they're Alpha
they're going to Branch off on their own
so you have to
already accept that but on Alpha you'll
probably make more money on them in a
shorter period of time but when they
leave they're gone so you better make
sure that you you know squeeze them dry
but you did in the body but you you did
set them up and you gave them the
knowledge to take it to the next level
it's not really squeezing if they're
getting fulfilled with your money yeah
and that allows them to get to the next
level because you gave them the
structure so that's what I'm doing now
I'm just looking for young talent to
people hey okay you're good at this
um I look for people who are talented
that don't want to be the face and of
course talented introverts that's the
key bro that is
talented introverts and they're out
there there's a lot of young talented
introverts that they don't want to be
the face you know so how are you finding
them on Craigslist no I just ask them to
do like I'll find them hey instead of me
having my own uh writer let me contract
a bunch of writers out there okay who's
got something that's like oh that [ __ ]
hit you know okay let me see if they hit
again how you finding them though
um just social they they all are they're
all trying to do their own social like
okay this person all right this they
have this thing that's good but this
thing's not good okay maybe I can
fulfill this like they're dming you and
stuff I'll DM them I'll DM them oh okay
so you know so that's how I'm starting
to find uh that's how I'm investing now
because that's a a smaller investment
yeah you know with real estate let's say
you you me find a house now you remember
bidding over it but if I find an
introverted talented person how are you
gonna you don't see them they're not 10
other people uh going to them only I am
it's like getting a girl while she's not
pretty yet well she still have her
braces on and you invest in they take
her glasses off yeah she's a hot chick
yeah so you're looking but you don't
want things only in private
groups only with the dance is there yeah
you're like I know you're not ready yet
but once you take them braces off I
could see the potential
gotta find them now and then if you have
the money like we just hit you know once
I hit 100 000 followers I just like was
the easiest for me to like start going
into it that's what I talked to you last
time like you you guys have a you know
you have your people and you just gotta
start digging into them okay let me
check out their resume okay what else I
did no we suck at that bro
we're not good at business no it's just
what are these views for
fun
that's it
you're saying you're a great businessman
but all I could think about is well if
you don't want to get all white doves
why don't we paint them blue or
something and then they fly and then
they match the color of the sky but you
got I bird eyes just floating but they
don't come back if the dirt if the doves
came back for round two and three okay
we're like a boomerang yeah if they
don't it's like and they're gone dude
you guys have a feather left like dude
that's a lot of money just to keep a
feather you know where you [ __ ] up you
need to meet some gambling Chinese Cooks
at the restaurant because what they did
is they would train their doves and they
would do Dove races
you ever heard of Dove Races they do
Dove races it's like pigeon races you
ever heard of Dove races are having the
same conversation
officially lost then you can get your
doves back yeah yeah I gotta work on
that man because that's a good return on
dubs is what you're saying you're saying
you're waiting for the market to turn
what is it going to turn into uh I think
I think when the market right now I
think it's squeezing out all the people
uh middle class people who jumped in and
invest I think all those people are
getting squeezed out because the people
are like a 2020 or 20 20 20 21 it's like
someone got lucky but they didn't
prepare for the market going down and
now they have to unload uh so they
bought too much they bought too much or
or they bought too much or they didn't
buy understanding what they bought it's
like oh remember I told you the guy who
hustled me out of my my uh Bentley for
my Lambo
that's what I that's what happened to me
you know it's like so you just sit there
and you wait for these guys to spend
spend spend and you just follow them
around like okay so and so has this all
right let me write it down oh they're
gonna for sure sell this I have this guy
here's a watch I am watching but I'm
watching my buddy lose his money right
now I don't say his name for someone
everyone here but like he's losing his
money right now like who all right I'm
gonna I already know what I'm gonna ask
for that Panera sure waiting to strike
yeah I'm going to strike but I'm being
supportive April I'm glad he bought it
but I am supportive I'm a Cheerleader
yeah
but of course
I am not wishing for the worse but if it
does happen I'm Billy I'm bailing him
out technically because if I did it you
know but at 30 40 off and he's probably
gonna get it worse if he went to a pawn
shop correct so you got to look at so
you check eBay right away and you check
a couple things so you know I think uh
what I learned from being an
entrepreneur from losing everything
people who make money make it on other
people who are losing money
it's uh that's why they say it's a
zero-sum life is zero sum if someone's
losing it someone's making someone's
making it someone's losing it you know
and if you are you know they say your
net worth your net worth is your net net
worth so if you're around a lot of
people who are out there entrepreneurs
there's gonna be people who win and lose
if you are the smart one you sit back
and use weight
and then you just pick it up or hey men
you know hey uh Bart I got this d uh
they come here I have this deal but I
have no money to buy okay well how much
is in it let me see let me pull up the
address oh there's 80 grand I give you
30 but I'll buy it for you but you don't
have to buy it you just need someone
who's richer like hey I'll flip this
thing for you for 80. when you can sell
for 100 something
so you just have to have everything
ready just waiting
so if something has 80. think about if
you have
and you don't know anyone like you've
never gotten you're afraid like someone
might not pay me
so if I go hey that deal has 80. I'm
gonna give you 30.
right now on the spot today so now I
have 110. no now you got 30. yeah 30 you
still need another 50. you get the deal
yeah that's so nice let's say let's say
I'm gonna hit there's 80 like we have to
flip this to someone else but there's 80
here but I'll give you 30 right now
because I have I have them in my back
pocket to buy right now then I go flip
and I'll keep 50 but I didn't you found
you brought me the deal so there's gonna
be a lot of these young people who
they're trying to get inspired and make
money and hustle if you just educate
them and you're cool about and you're
transparent don't bring it to you yeah
and then then you have to see like is it
worth it but if you spend money on doves
Ferraris and twenty thousand dollar uh
champagne bottles then you can't buy it
when they come through the door you're
not ready you know you got to be ready
or you buy a lot of it and it disappears
yeah like Luna
so that's what I've been up the only
scouting Talent scouting Talent looking
for see who's losing their money right
now there's a lot of people that shit's
getting tight they say that uh more
millionaires are made during crashes
than during like like good Market times
100 I agree and that's because people
are buying up [ __ ] I told you guys about
Apple it's coming down so you're gonna
buy Apple when it's down I'm waiting for
it to hit I wanted 132 I think it hit
like in the 120s because one uh in the
high 120s today's video is brought to
you by DraftKings baby the NFL playoff
picture is locked in and my go-to plays
for my Wild Card action is DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL to kick off the road
to Super Bowl 57 new customers could
just bet five dollars and get 200 and
free bets instantly plus all new and
existing customers can get uh no sweat
bet each day of the Wild Card round this
week can't just place any NFL bet of
your choice and if it loses you'll get a
free BET back up to ten dollars action's
so good right by NFL playoffs anywhere
else so like I'm pretty excited about
the Chiefs the Eagles oh the Bucks can't
forget the Giants California baby the
Bengals and what's really cool about
betting right now since the playoffs
just started right they're saying that
all the teams are equal but you can look
at the betting markets and they're
saying hey some people are already
favorites so if you bet on the right
teams you can make good Moolah download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app and use
the code off the Record new customers
can bet five dollars on the NFL and get
203 bets instantly oh yeah only at
draftking sports book with code off the
Record minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details I know what do you think is
going to go back up to 180 at least it's
gonna at least go back to where it was
especially inflation it's not as sexy as
crypto flip those like 10x to gain dude
I was like that's scary right now
but really
um the patient guys are just basically
they're not greedy if you think about it
like when people are that are over
leveraging you're so [ __ ] greedy
because you're buying up more than you
can
and then it bites you in the butt so you
have to get saved I think they are
greedy they just have good impulse
control so they're like they're patient
greedy because the people that I know
that are ballers are [ __ ] hungry
they're hungrier than I ever will be
but for me I'm like I want to make it in
one swoop like I want to buy OMG payment
I'm gonna out those guys like I can stay
consistent for 20 years but their
appetite is humongous
so I'm like these guys are green they're
just impulse controls just too good it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah they see all the I
think they they see all the Angles and
they just sit and they wait and I think
they do have a lot of money and they
don't show it and they just sit there
and they wait and they wait and I could
let me grab a little hair grab a little
there if something's out there they'll
grab it because they are patient and
they are real I'm not they're not gonna
leave a dollar on the table Yeah but
they will grab but they won't go like I
need it right away they're like okay
plus if they're already Ballin it's a
different emotional thing or it's not
emotional because it's like you know
gamified you can maybe see more clearly
you're like not balling you're like
betting on one thing you're like so
invested everything is like about that
you know what I mean you get scared you
overthink [ __ ] you know I'm really just
talking about ourselves one guy I know
treats every deal like it's the last
deal on the [ __ ] you need to
chill the [ __ ] out you're rich
I don't know man the very last deal he's
ever gonna have
so let's say uh you [ __ ] Scout some
sick ass Talent like right now I have
some person they're good at running uh
Facebook ads Facebook ads yeah Facebook
and Instagram answers and he's running
ads for what's a mortgage uh no they're
not I found them somewhere else because
with what's a mortgage I never want to
mix business with what's a mortgage
because I have so many hands in the
cookie jar with so I find I use the
what's a mortgage brand like oh I want
to work with uh with the short Asian guy
cool all right what do you do all right
let me see what you do and here I uh I
have this one guy can you run his ads
and let's see how it goes like all right
cool like by the time by the way they
explain their procedure you're like okay
this person knows what they're gonna do
they know how to do it and then I give
them one account oh I know so-and-so
will want to run your ad uh wants to run
uh run ad so try it all right it's
working all right maybe a little more in
the first time I always have this person
pay them and not take a single dollar so
they feel that
I'm not trying to scrape off because
then they like what's a thousand bucks
gonna do for me not much but that person
that thousand bucks might be a big deal
so like oh cool let me get them
comfortable into so that they make the
money that they can pay their bills be
happy not think about their other job
okay once that is secure then you'll get
the I'm here all right so now moving
forward this is what we're gonna do
kind of like a pin but not really yeah
yeah yeah like a talent manager you're
correct but everyone wants to take their
school first like if I get my piece
first they're never gonna be able to
leave their other job because most
people have other these kids have other
jobs they're doing other things where
if they can find a way not to do that
anymore you are like the Savior right if
I came in just like a pimp oh my God he
can't even save my dad I don't have to
how do I get my ass beat anymore you
know no more gang bangs you know like
that's right girl
I got new medical insurance too
homeboy Room 205
that makes me understand business yeah
right Anthony's like I've been to 205.
yeah
I mean that's that makes a lot of sense
but people are too short-sighted and
greedy yeah so what most people will do
is they'll find talent and they'll
basically skin the Sheep that's to say
they don't they don't they want it all
for themselves so then when you work in
that Partnership if it's a unfair
you know balance that person is going to
eventually burn out and be like [ __ ]
this I have to work my regular job and
like you're only paying me like 10 cents
on the dollar like [ __ ] this right then
in that situation it's like it's uneven
and I think people will burn out quick
but in your case it's like oh well
I'd rather be doing my passion so you're
giving me this opportunity to do that
then I'm gonna stick with you and I'm
gonna be loyal to you
yeah you have garyvee's Mom you're like
is it yeah I see like a lot of people
who Branch off they do I haven't heard
one person say anything negative about
garyvee where they were his videographer
or they did his marketing and then they
left they had anything negative to say
or they had to sign ndas but I've never
heard anything or they legally can't say
anything bad India's don't hold people
back though people still talk it doesn't
like legally it's supposed to but people
just talk a bit it depends how you scare
them you know if you scare them like the
white way or the right way the right way
you gotta roll up hard you know like
Suge Knight then you're like okay if
Suge Knight told me ND I'm like I'm
gonna shut the [ __ ] up I don't even need
a side anything yeah yeah I don't even
know who Suge Knight is yes never heard
of them I learned like uh watching that
movie Ben Hur I know it's an old school
I know you keep your horses fed they run
further and farther and they get you
where you need to be if you [ __ ] on your
horses they [ __ ] they fall they die
you can't finish the race oh I was
trying to connect Suge Knight to bend
her and I was like damn it's gonna be a
crazy one
and I'll do the in the races like the
horses that were healthy is run further
the one that didn't try to Ram other
horse or other chariots and kept running
just stay on their race and I gotta hit
this one hit that one you're like you're
treating your horses back when you just
want to bang them up just because you
want to prove something but you let them
keep going they're going to finish the
race and you're going to make it to the
end of the race isn't it just so much
easier to just you know
[Laughter]
save a lot of time no work here
no work here you've got a lot of doves
green doves blue doves yellow doves I
got three tickets man that's a 30 chance
that's a good idea I've been day trading
that's like day trading's like that but
yeah this is like day trading yeah I'm a
day trader
every day I buy what have you been day
trading just buy just buy just one I opt
to do option trading and the reason why
I got into it you get all these uh you
guys get negative comments I get the
trolls dude you guys got you guys have
trolls for sure I had what are your
realtor buddies on I had one of your
realtor Buddies go live with me and all
they did was just we're talking about
you guys I was like damn these oh man
yeah I was oh yeah how was that it's
solid and except for some three or four
trolls came in and they were just
talking about you guys I don't like the
I'm like
oh she blocked their comments oh [ __ ]
where's dick or something like that like
dude some guy said that
I had to like freeze my thumbs up like
my fat thumbs are blocking the screen oh
[ __ ] okay I had a and then as I do just
blocking these guys you suck first no
some guy said it about it all about Anne
and then it and then so I just blocked
so I like he kept on saying a couple
mean things and then he said that one
line so I just blocked it really quick
might have just been a crazy dude yeah
but I'm like dude I think that was me I
think I was drunk that day yeah I was
like dude it was crazy how did you how
did you meet
um he just hit me up on DM then I'm
messing back and forth and then I didn't
know that you knew him that well until I
saw or you guys doing that well until I
saw the comments start rolling in when I
went live with him I'm like oh [ __ ] they
must know him well
oh that was crazy wait so
ancestor dude
confirm it yeah confirm yeah I was like
what
that's why you moved to Vegas yeah yeah
there was like three guys who were like
just just throwing just mean stuff over
and over again dude so constantly talk
about dick sucking huh but yeah but
these trolls like oh there's what you
say is impossible there's no way you
know there's two types of people there's
people that when they see something like
cool how can I achieve that too another
set of people when they see something
they go man they come up yeah you can't
do that they come up with 20 different
reasons and let's see where they're at
yeah people tell me like okay well I
can't there's no way I can save 300
bucks a week or a thousand bucks a month
like in my job or my career so last
November not this uh November 2022 but
November 2021 let me find a trade that I
don't know anything about and I probably
can put all my energy into it can I make
money or not and now I know like if
there's a will there's a way so I
started Trading from November up until
August I made lost money I was down like
15 grand and then from August moving
forward I've been making money every day
and through trading how much money are
you making like today I made 740 just in
30 minutes on Monday I made 1700 bucks
in an hour wow so I'm averaging about
500 bucks a day pretty consistently now
wow but it's like so I know if you want
something bad enough you can pick a
trade and will into existence yeah so
that's like a slam dunk to saying
dude I didn't know [ __ ] and I'm still
[ __ ] crushing it the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
you so I say it that way but not
that you know that's the layman's term
it's a beautiful because it's it's very
inspiring at least to me because it's
like well it took you very little time
to learn all that and you're still
making money
um and there's you know the people that
talk [ __ ] to you they're still talking
[ __ ] yeah and they still haven't made
anything close yeah so it's crazy so
that's why I know like I did it just to
because some people they need
inspiration you know if you can Inspire
enough people then you can influence
them now when you want to sell them win
coffee boom sell it right but you can't
do that if you can't inspire people to
yeah to better themselves or like they
they want they want hope is that your
goal 500 bucks a day and you need to I'm
trying to get to a thousand bucks a day
by first quarter if I can get to uh four
thousand bucks that's like a meal a year
then because and another reason why I
was doing it I didn't know rates were
gonna pull back so you imagine like all
these loan officers Realtors who want to
leave the industry or change careers
like okay either change careers put your
tell between your legs and change career
or find a way to wait it out and when I
waited it out in 2007 2000 seven you
know like I said people make money when
the crash is happening but you have to
be there waiting to make money yeah
so different that's [ __ ] tight I
don't know
but it's still hard like I'm sitting
here with my ass this tight like please
[ __ ] please raise pull back what what
rate would make you or in your business
really happy if I think if rates hit the
low fives I'll be happy because if rates
go up Gates will open again yeah I think
it's like getting people in at a steady
Pace if rates are off to the fourth oh
people are gonna come out the woodwork
and then you have all these
pre-approvals but you can't get your
offer accepted because you have 20 guys
writing the offer on the same house at
flow fives they're trickling in you can
get when you make money you want it to
be consistent and fluent like that
there's no hiccups but when it hits the
force like they show they wrote 20
offers you're doing all these
pre-approvals and it's like they're not
getting their offer accepted and you're
going through the it's like
on to the next you can't if they're
taking a while to get their offer
accepted
so that's why I think low fives is going
to be where it's at for it like I hope
don't drop under low fives because
then you have a flood game and you have
too many yeah too many got it but that's
on for your business the mortgage
business correct but for the consumer
it's good the lower the interest lower
the interest rate correct
foreign